сейви рибників у охорони об'єкта не
покійні політичним настроєм і в
Франції вже не одне десятиліття вин
живуть він речі за двісті кілометрів від
парижа у team такого за його словами та ще
не було
всі на рику і тупотіли так і за позбавила їх
на виробляючі сам робити
спаривается на прямого емануелем акрон а
формуємо по ну я його економічний
орендований політичний курс і ми
повернем акрон видав інший тур виборів у
проте не все і у дант
болять за нього я буду тут багата хто
Петро і мій національний фронт, причому він
і його ненавидь кажуть в процесі відкрито
кордон був табу
те що вона йому вірна як змінилося
зараз і своїх симпатій на нові і у
дантисте врубає ники в кучері
вин ситі по горло політичними
скандалами взятих вчать кандидата вигляд
консерваторію франсуа фійону і до і не
формального батова що він одержав на
роботу людина своєї батьківщини ти ж відриви
води хороший нас правді на протиріч
ми невірно витого що буває все
політесі
заважаючи в тій відтяжці про в'язницю щоб
фінансово особах людей я за марин ле пен
треба ви пробували частину але в міні не
соромно вид критого коза ти відсоток
а може і 20 вай у тима, що налетів у
люди померлого туру проголосують за
національний фронт які шанси на пари
мову в марін ле пен
жадібних поважаючи бургомістр друзів вінс
пенман а ще в іншому торі і всі партії
збіднюється щоб забезпечити та пари можуть
У фіналі фіналіст і результату донзе
едобро скарги на страусі їй франції він і
ми запалили голосуємо і тактики вся франція
були репрезентативними для сільської
місцевості
з ти по вам і традиції ми і зіницями
багата сімей живуть тут воно одне
покоління ще тут багата на пенсіонерів
як єврейська країна кредо activity
порожня і всіх перебити їхній вибір чаю
компанії ж і наші ніш зазвучати за
шанується пенсіонерка зданий zenfone мій
Антоша і пахти дуже важко загнутий ще
вікторія шкіри з кандидатів
на кшталт бас пантелича я віддаю балад у
людей роботи мати виберу в астані хули
ну як би можуть і біля кабінки для
голосування
[музика]